Any suggestions for low platelet cuts? So there is one, there are several things that can help with low platelet codes.
So what is the, what's called a mutable pro? Yeah, that's what it's called.
So a mutable pro is a product that has been shown to help with low platelet codes. The only thing I don't like about it is that it's expensive.
It's, and you have to, the studies show that using it, that's this product right here, the studies using it, used a lot of them. So it gets to be a very pricey product.
But this is from Belgian ski foundation, but they have some really good studies showing that it could help with low platelets.
See, it's $148 for this bottle. It has 10 pills in it.
Holy, jumping up and down. It's a very pricey product.
The other thing that you can try is the red root tinsure from herb farm.
This product right here has been shown to help with low platelet codes as well.
This is $14 for a bottle of this. This would be worth trying.
Ultimately, you have to deal with the reason why the person has low platelet codes. That is usually the cancer.
So you're still doing everything you possibly can for the cancer.
Fabulous.